après ta première élimination il dit tu
as eu de la chance de réintégrer
l'émission toi oui je fais partie de
ceux qui sont eu de la chance c'est euh
d'essayer d'aller plus loin mais manque
de chance je me suis fait rattraper ça
c'est pas super bien passé hein tu as
réintégration
je tombe dans l'équipe adverse compliqué
de
de d'aller plus loin avec eux si jamais
on avait gagné j'aurais pu aller plus
loin mais deux choses ils ont perdu donc
forcément j'étais la rouge éjectable tu
regrettes
d'avoir fait le bail là sur le non je
rigole non non c'était bien c'était une
bonne aventure c'est une bonne
expérience le seul chose que je peux
louper ou alors ce que ce qui m'a manqué
c'est d'aller plus loin c'est tout
bah ouais c'est dur ou bien c'est
vraiment dur c'est vrai vraiment c'est
vraiment dur on mange pas on est fatigué
on il y a tout ça qui est mis comme si
tu faisais Ramadan et sur une île voilà
exactement encore plus dur avec des
épreuves en plus avec des épreuves mais
je crois que le plus dur c'est l'humain
on peut être fort on peut être nul mais
contrôler l'humain c'est vraiment dur
euh alors après ta première élimination
donc Rudy tu as eu la chance de
réintégrer l'émission bah ouais mais
c'était ça c'est pas super bien passé on
en parlait tout à l'heure regardez
j'espère que ça va bien se passer je
pense que ça va bien se passer
[Musique]
que ça toute la journée
ça c'est le plus important qu'il est
arrivé c'est collier collier et puis
mets les pieds sous la table et puis il
boit dans la dose qu'on lui a rempli
gentiment on sait que Koh-Lanta se
dépasse un hôtel maintenant je vais
faire attention à ce que je fais moi
parler je pense que comme il a pas à
pêché il aurait dû peut-être attendre
qu'on le serve et il aurait eu sa part
on fait profite pas et quand il faudra
faire des des stratégies on le fera je
pense que je suis un peu tendu à cause
de la fin et du sommeil donc j'ai ravalé
ma langue sinon j'aurais je suis passé
en mode Hulk manqué de finesse et ça pas
le faire
[Musique]
est-ce que quand Denis Brogniart
vraiment il explique comme dans
Koh-Lanta
Sophie je vais donc enlever mon slipse
[Rires]
dans la merde
Rudy
ce que j'ai le plus aimé c'est que tu as
tenté le tout pour le tout tu as fait un
coup de bœuf non tout le monde se
souvient tu as fait croire que tu avais
un collier j'adore les frères tu l'as
fait comment le collier en fait ils
vendent des faux colliers
[Rires]
à un collier des petits des petits fils
des petits coquillages j'ai découpé la
main sur la main il y avait des
coquillages avec des filets ça
ressemblait ça pouvait ressembler à un
collier donc j'ai découpé en secret je
suis parti en forêt j'ai monté mon mon
petit scénario et comme Nicolas est à
côté de moi et que c'était le mieux
placé pour pour faire un début de
scénario et ben j'ai balancé mon mon
scénario et lui il y a cru il a dit à
tous les autres et forcément Nicolas
c'est celui qu'on croit donc tout le
monde a cru mon scénario et donc et à la
fin c'est passé à la fête à la base
c'est passé hein c'est juste à cause
d'une question la question qui est le
talisman avant le collier et forcément
ça m'a ça m'a mis dedans regarde
je vais faire le cinéma de la mort genre
je vais crier ah je l'ai trouvé
[Musique]
il a trouvé par là
je sais pas je l'ai juste sorti avec
je l'ai vu dans son chapeau avec des
cocktails si jamais je réussis à gagner
à mon sorcier
je pense que tu pourrais rester dans les
adresses celui-là Rudy les aventuriers
de la tribu jaune ont décidé de vous
éliminer et leur sentence et tirer votre
[Applaudissements]
juste avant le décompte
[Rires]
ce jour là à quelques
instants
pourquoi tu vas pas sur la plage
peut-être les revoir
on sait jamais
exactement alors hier c'était le grand
retour de l'épreuve de la dégustation
d'insectes sur le problème elle a
beaucoup été commenté commenté critiqué
sur les réseaux je trouvais que c'était
horrible à regarder et qu'il y avait
trop à manger en même temps c'est vrai
que là ils y sont allés
il y a une entrée un plat et un dessert
[Musique]
de cocotiers une seule oblig
ation arracher la tête avant de manger
chaque verre
de la chair de coquillages et d'un côté
un scorpion de l'autre un œil moyen de
poisson un énorme
œil de poisson une brochette composée de
scorpion de blatte et de scarabée avec
en plus un verre de cocotiers et bon
appétit bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
ça fait allez deux semaines qu'on mange
pas tout ce qui vient je l'aurais pris
tu t'entraînes avant tu vas manger des
trucs pas avant d'y aller pas du tout
pas du tout mais de toute façon ce qu'il
faut se dire c'est que tout ce qui est
là c'est comestible donc retirer ces
premières appréhension et hop il y a des
mois et tu t'es entraîné tu t'étais
entraîné à l'épreuve des poteaux ou pas
dans son
train
non en fait avec ma condition normale je
pensais que ça allait suffire mais pas
et en fait non pas du tout non on y va
là-bas faut être mieux préparé il faut
faire attention à tout une meilleure non
si jamais j'avais su comment c'était
réellement
forcément j'aurais fait une meilleure
condition à la piscine voilà tu t'es dit
ouais tu t'es dit ouais non je peux y
aller tranquille avec Michael
je peux je pourrais le faire et en fait
non
[Rires]
ils sont plutôt dépassés
on vient pour ça on vient pour se
dépasser on vient pour manger des choses
qu'on a pas l'habitude de manger voilà
et je trouve pas que c'était exagéré
alors il y a un candidat c'est une
première
il assure qu'il fait des preuves il
avait tellement la dalle qu'il a battu
le record de rapidité de l'émission tu
avais l'impression qu'il était dans un
resto gastronome
ok top Nicolas
allez le plus vite possible
ok tant qu'on Nicolas quelle vitesse
astronomique j'ai imaginé des saucisses
des petites saucisses et j'ai tellement
faim que ça m'a pas du tout dérangé ça
fait du bien de manger
toi ici Sophie
[Rires]
qui a totalement loupé son épreuve c'est
Esteban Zia Tao les Cités d'Or le roi de
la loose depuis le début c'est le seul
qui a réussi à ne rien manger du tout et
il a encore fait perdre toute son équipe
tout le monde avait la je raconte
[Applaudissements]
allez allez allez
malheureusement Tania Frédéric Esteban
et Clémence c'est terminé j'en ai marre
Denis j'en ai marre de passer à côté de
chaque confort
able
sur les trucs sur les audiences etc et
moi en tant que téléspectatrice
cette séquence là j'ai envie de zapper
parce que ça me met des hauts le coeur
ça je trouve que c'est un peu un peu
long par rapport à David est-ce que
c'est pas contre-productif
cette preuve là je vais je vais demander
je me connais pas
je vais demander aux équipes t'inquiète
pas
t'emmerde pas avec ça l'épisode d'hier
soir était celui des moches adoré cette
épreuve et tout voilà moi c'est ce que
j'ai aimé était l'épreuve des c'était
celui des destins liés chaque candidat
était réuni en binôme par tirage au sort
et le destin pour certaines personnes a
fait mal les choses puisque vu que ça
fait 30 jours qu'il galère à rien
bouffer sur une île il n'y a plus aucun
filtre entre les candidats ça y est vous
vous dites tout au bout d'un moment si
tu trouves quelqu'un qui est nul tu le
dis il est nul
au début on se retient et après la
fatigue ça part tout seul ça part tout
seul c'est comme Denis
regrouper deux par deux
ce sont les destins liés Esteban vous
serez associés à Clémence
je suis satisfait est-ce que je sais pas
si c'est le capot Clémence
il est souvent placé malheureusement
dans les derniers donc ça ne rassure pas
Frédéric vous serez associés à Tania
première réaction Frédéric pour être
honnête Tania c'est pas du tout mon
premier choix
elle peut faire mieux que ce qu'elle a
fait depuis le début elle ne peut que
faire mieux
alors il y en a une qui ne supporte
vraiment pas son binôme c'est Clémence
en même temps c'est normal puisqu'elle
s'est retrouvée avec Esteban Esteban en
fait je crois qu'il savait pas où il
allait je crois qu'il a pris à
l'aéroport et à mon avis il a dû faire
une erreur de destination elle le
support tellement pas qu'elle a
totalement pété un plomb ça c'était une
vraie vraie rigolade
j'en ai marre de me taper à chaque fois
les boulets tout le monde s'occupait
incapable de se transcender de faire
quoi que ce soit c'est le vide il y a
rien je fais quoi moi avec ça encore une
fois le destin il est pas avec moi
[Musique]
c'était vraiment la loose toute la
journée il a même été atteint sur le
camp d'une Castaldi aiguë vous allez
comprendre regarde
Esteban n'est pas en forme
quelle bête tu as piqué
je ressemble à l'efforts au niveau des
yeux et surtout l'oeil gauche qui est
hyper gonflé si j'ai pas mes yeux
comment je fais pour trouver un collier
pas de collier on dirait un maquillage
de cinéma
et bien embauché le coup
incroyable
après c'est compliqué pour lui parce
qu'il se retrouve à peu près le seul
rouge de
avec lui lors de cette épreuve alors je
vais dire la vérité perso c'était mon
pote là-bas c'était mon binôme
non mais je pense que si jamais j'aurais
été avec lui je pense pas que ce serait
passé pareil mais il se retrouve avec
des gens qui a pas de il a pas beaucoup
d'affinités donc tu penses que c'est ça
ouais je pense que c'est ça qui est bien
sympa
non je suis arrêté bien sympa moi je
l'aime bien moi aussi c'était magnifique
c'est un peu
je te vois comme Esteban là-bas
j'avais postuler mon refusé
elle lui prenais le oui alors on va
passer au tabac de la soirée Clémence
avait fait le pacte du petit doigt avec
les autres aventuriers pour ne pas qu'il
élimine ce geste pour Clémence signifier
beaucoup de choses mais vous allez voir
les tarbas de Koh-Lanta en ont décidé
autrement pour le duo Esteban et
Clémence regardez
ma grande sœur qui nous a quitté elle ne
mutinait jamais la main mais le petit
doigt donc
ressortir ce geste c'est très symbolique
moi je suis toujours sur toujours là
dessus on est d'accord sur mon petit
doigt et tout je vote contre toi ce soir
Esteban et par conséquent Clémence aussi
c'est une petite revanche pour le coup
de Gilles et Esteban les aventuriers
d'attribuer réunifier ont décidé de vous
éliminer et leur sentence est
irrévocable et vous entraîner Clémence
dans votre chute Clémence les
aventuriers de la tribu réunifiée ont
décidé de vous éliminer et leur sentence
est irrévocable
[Applaudissements]
on approche on est sur la fin du jeu il
y a que du mensonge si tu Poker Face ok
reste plus que 6 personnes on approche à
la fin on va dire que il y a beaucoup
d'alliance tout le monde fait des
alliances arrivé à un moment on fait des
alliances avec des avec des ennemis et
qu'on sent qu'on peut les éliminer on va
les illuminer si tu peux c'était du
poker face à ce moment là qu'est-ce que
tu penses qui va gagner tu penses là
franchement tout est jouable tout est
jouable tu te fous de ma gueule qui va
gagner
[Rires]
je dirais bien Frédéric Laura Julie
Tania campagne
le meilleur le meilleur dans les celui
qui mérite au plus on va dire si jamais
tout si jamais on du coup tout le monde
Nicolas c'est le c'est le bon prétendant
c'est favoris quoi alors laura est une
bonne favorite aussi Frédéric aussi
Quentin
de la politique
elle joue au tennis
dans les parages c'est pas complètement
hasby qu'est-ce que tu veux bah là où
vous avez totalement raison c'est que
c'est un épisode de légende franchement
c'est un épisode de légendaire la
stratégie les mensonges le coup de
binaire
il y a tout dedans plus le coup de
théâtre à la fin et tout ça et que ça
fasse une audience si modérée ça prouve
que Koh-Lanta la marque est altéré non
pas du tout c'est le jeu mardi tu le
mets le vendredi je te dis que ça fera
beaucoup plus simple changeons vite
parce que 35 pour cet épisode de
l'aisance c'est pas possible payer c'est
mal payé c'est mal payé merci mon Rudy
d'avoir été là mon chéri